because you're too scared to be yourself
Lizzie you're one of the kinds but that
isn't exactly a good thing at first you
come off as a self-absorbed and moody
teenager who thinks everyone worships
the ground she walks on but our
perception of you is starting to change
you have a lot of issues to work out but
you're starting to come around you've
proven that you'll go the extra mile for
those who care about so we hope you
won't jump ship on you and Josie's 22nd
birthday everything will be different in
season two of legacies but are things
going to take a turn for the better or
the worst keep watching to find out if
season two will cover Landon's full
lineage hopes whereabouts and exactly
what happened to mullah voor you've got
to be kidding me
hope may the ultimate sacrifice when she
jumped into the mala 4 puddle she
convinced Alaric to burn all references
of her and she cast a mimic spell on
Clarke forcing him to jump into the
puddle with her
this happens moments after hope and
Landon defeat the headless horseman and
confess their love for each other for
the moment everything is up in the air
and it would appear that hope Mickelson
has been erased from existence but
surely legacies can't survive without
its leading lady which brings us to our
first theory I blew that hope once lived
fans are certain that someone will find
a clue that hope once lived
chances are Josie will be the one to
find out about hope sacrifice after all
she does have Penelope's notebook this
[Music]
records all of it so she should have
access to all the pieces of the puzzle
we just hope that Josie will work
quickly because hope is trapped in a
Hell dimension but luckily she won't be
alone folk Clark and the endless
blackness after Clark through the
chalice into the puddle hope knew that
sacrificing herself was the only way to
stop malabar but she wasn't about to
take a trip into a puddle of endless
blackness alone so she cast a mimic
spell on Clark and brought him down with
her we're guessing that hope and Clark
are going to have to work together to
escape malov or which is going to be
super interesting we wouldn't be
surprised if hoping Clark became chummy
in season two because in the end they'll
only have each other when will Hope
resurface it's safe to assume that
all the main characters will be
reprising their roles in season 2 but
now that their memories of hope have
been wiped clean there's no way of
knowing how their personalities will
change according to the episode lists of
season 2 hope will resurface in episode
2 but not without paying a price the
only way hope can escape is by releasing
all the monsters that have been absorbed
by the pit so that means that Klaus
Elijah and Hayley might also emerge from
the puddle but how these characters will
affect the plot of season 2 remains to
be seen the new kids on campus
a handful of brand new characters will
join the cast of legacies in season 2
and one of them is played by descendants
star Thomas Doherty Thomas will place
the bastion a revered bloodsucker with a
hidden agenda besides Sebastian new
characters like Professor of Artemis
played by Alexis Denisof
sheriff Mac played by Bianca Kajlich and
the sheriff's kids Ethan and Maya played
by Leo Howard and Bianca Santos
respectively will be also joining the
production we can also expect to see
Freya and Ty pop up in season two which
is something fans are dying to see now
that we know who will be joining the
cast let's jump right into some season 2
predictions Alaric will get fired
Alaric left his fate as headmaster up to
his students but with most of the honor
council missing the choice is up to
Josie and Caleb
if Alaric gets voted out we can expect
to see a very different side of him in
season two professor of Artemis may
replace Alaric as headmaster which could
allow Alaric to spend his time solving
the Enigma that is hope the twin merge
Josie and Lizzie may have their
differences but the last thing they want
is to absorb the other so one of the
twins may choose to become a heretic in
season two to escape the curse the
Gemini coven you were as much a part of
this cycle as I am since Josie took the
bullet for Lizzie during the season one
finale we wouldn't be surprised if
Lizzie turned into a heretic to stop the
merger problem is Lizzie might do this
for selfish reasons because becoming a
heretic would make her stronger than her
sister new couples old wounds with hope
gone and looks like Landon and Josie are
warming up to each other but
well Landon fall for hope when she gets
back or will he have no idea who she is
we're in for some real couple drama and
season two fans predicts that hope and
Raphael will become an item when she
turns him back into a human is mala Bohr
gone for good well the short answer is
no while the gates to mala 4 might be
closed Malibu isn't going anywhere just
yet
he's the Baltimore of legacies and he's
just getting started
once hope escapes in episode 2 there's a
good chance malgor will rise from the
mud the host landon kirby is the son
malov or always wanted but for all the
wrong reasons
he wants to use Landon's body as a host
which would basically make him in moral
considering Landon is a Phoenix
we believe that Malabar will take over
Landon's body in the season 2 finale
which would make him the villain of
season 3 what powers do you think Landon
has and which couple are you shipping
sound off in the comments below thanks
for watching don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to the things we'll
catch you next time
[Music]